300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah subhanahu wa tala's book like
you've never had before assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends once again
there's an outright attack on the family
unit from the religion liberalism
brother sisters yeah and this is a
religion this religion that is enforcing
us and shoving it down our thoughts to
follow a specific opinion and world
world view yes not only that they are
bombing countries yeah they are bombing
us to accept this yeah and that's even
failing sadly now i want to get straight
into this problem sisters which is a
movie or uh which you've been playing on
amazon prime and i'll be honest any time
i'm on the underground going like i see
this jamie jamie james who dated jamie
james bond who is he we don't know who
he is but we found out uh
um by doing a bit of research that's the
panel that it's crazy because if you
watch it brother and sisters in that
very movie it's very bizarre that they
did not pick you know jamie is somebody
who is a drag queen who is a boy who
wants to dress up as a woman um so he's
not necessarily a transgender but he's
also identified as a homosexual gay
person who wants to dress up as a woman
and very interestingly his best friend
is a muslim woman a muslim girl hijab
hijabi but sadly not wearing they drive
in the correct way uh sisters you know
it's a pandemic i'm see well like i'm
saying everywhere you know showing that
i just do not understand you know you
cover your hair to start well it's just
for the sake of allah is it worth having
a massive distance between you and allah
with a few inches of hair but anyways
just a little reminder but that's not
topic today the point is this brother
and sisters yeah this issue here is
nothing new allah talks about this in
the quran this is nothing new brothers
and sisters yeah and it all derives from
where yeah it derives from where you
liberalism utilitarianism brother
sisters and who is the father one of the
founding fathers
john stuart mill and who's john stewart
inspired by who else can it be accept a
police hello brothers and sisters what
did ibleese do yeah and this is not
coincidence utilitarianism so it's all
about you it's about me and what is this
principle it's an ethical choice for the
greatest good for the greatest number
of people of course yeah without causing
harm what's very bizarre is that i'm
going to show you some studies from this
book as well that you don't want to
cause harm to others but it allows you
to cause harm to yourself because
there's consent involved or is there
consent or prayer pressure brothers and
sisters in this very movie the scene
which i find it very strange like i said
before so you don't see a jew or a
christian playing that role but it's a
muslim why a muslim because we're at the
forefront brothers and sisters that's
exactly what's happening you know and
they just they're not only that the
issue is not here to propagate jaime's
life view you know what he wants to
follow but it's also a subliminal blow
to the muslims and the hijabis and the
brothers yes who do why to normalize
this be okay with this this is okay be
like the actor who's there not only does
she
allow him in his room which we know it's
all acting but she also defends him
towards the end now we're not seeing
that this person should be harmed
nobody's saying he should be hated what
we're trying to say is that this person
might be a vulnerable individual because
in the movie he says two things which is
very bizarre he's talking about mimi
mimi is this drag queen that he becomes
and he is jamie he says mimi is ugly
jaime is ugly and he talks about mimi is
you know when he's mimi nobody can stop
him it's powerful but when he's jaime
he's pathetic so to me that seems like a
16 year old who has some kind of trouble
self identifying and i've said this
before if you're not happy with what you
are you will never be happy with what
you become and that's why islam teaches
us to submit and accept the will of god
and be happy with who you are guys when
i was young there were certain body
parts of myself like for example i was
very
when it came to my nose i thought my
nose was very big and why because the
society i lived in made me feel as if i
looked a certain way i wasn't happy it
the problem wasn't me yeah because i've
got the same nose
as you guys can see here can you guys
see yeah
alhamdulillah i'm happy with who i am
but i had peer pressure friends looking
cool this that so i can kind of resonate
with that you know but i was thinking
imagine if i went to a
like oh you know i want to get my nose
done and this why so i know peer
pressure plays a big part because i
suffered that myself
but and that's it it doesn't it doesn't
finish their problem sisters two things
i'm going to quote from here which is
going to leave you mind boggled yeah and
i'm going to get to this brother and
sisters but before i do that we spoke
about john stuart mill the founding one
of the founding fathers of
utilitarianism which is all about me me
me and that's what exactly iblis did
when allah told them the one who created
the heavens and earth can you imagine
your lord that has given you everything
he blessed iblis with a lot of things
and he told them bow down to adam he
said no
you know what that means no it's all
about me and what i want and my desires
and the maximum amount of pleasure for
me is what to never bow down to adam and
that is going to cause him to be in the
hellfire forever may allah destroy him
inshallah now
don't get involved sean i'm doing a
video here you shouldn't get invoked
there's academics talking here you're
actually intellectual eunuch
i mean
oh yeah
oh okay
the shampoo does something good we're
talking about me me and the one he
becomes is called me me as well yeah
okay so why is always me me okay now
brothers and sisters and to be honest
the panel if you think about it who said
having the maximum amount of pleasure is
good for you yeah we know people many
examples people who watch pornography
yeah there are men out there who cannot
get an erection to please their wives
why because they're watching pornography
and that is the only thing that they can
get an erection with so that's the
maximum amount of pleasure well guess
what your wife's not being pleased at
home brava yeah yeah you should feel the
subhanallah and we see this throughout
but anyways yeah or even talk about
alcohol yeah talk about alcohol yeah
drink alcohol amount of pleasure yeah
and one of the reasons of domestic
violence it's alcohol people dying
anyways now i'm going to read something
for you guys from sisters in december
2020 the high court rules for kiara bell
the course opinion was damning it noted
that defending this clinic had been
unable to explain the sudden rise in
teenage girls presenting at the clinic
for hormones and surgeries the clinic
had admitted that not a single minor
teacher teenage teenage girl had been
turned away from inability to provide
informal consent meaning the mum and dad
is not there they can draw at the clinic
and say look i want my breasts removed
there the high crop
the high court noted also that the
hormonal treatments came with a serious
health risk that side effects might
include loss of fertility and loss of
sexual function that the evidence based
for this treatment is yet highly
uncertain finally the court noted the
clinic's own admission for that young
woman who had begun the process of
hormonal transition had shown and shown
no over improvement in their mood or
psychological well-being using
standardized psychological
measures
two less breasts
and you're still at the same spot you
left
and i'm going to end on this stop bro
and sisters where did this all come from
this phenomena where did it come from
before 2012 in fact there was no
scientific literature on girls ages 11
to 21
ever having developed gender dysphoria
at all even in history this book says
that there was 0.1 of boys the question
is where did this
exponential growth come from
brothers and sisters
this is our point
where we're at life where we're at today
brothers sisters it's the course we have
given so much freedom to human beings
that they don't know what to be what
color to be when to be how to be
one becomes a piano one wants to chop
his breasts one's chopping his testicles
where do we stop
maximum amount of pleasure for maximum
amount of people
broken sisters like the prophet peace be
upon him said islam began as something
strange and it will end up something
strange glad times glad tidings to the
strangers assalamu alaykum
you